what I'm going to do here is explain to
you how to make carrot caviar what I had
in this is in this beaker here is carrot
juice normal supermarket carrot juice
mixed with sodium alginate which is an
extract from brown brown seaweed brown
algae so it's a totally natural chemical
it's pretty common you'll find it in a
food such as easy cheese or ice cream
and you can get it online now that your
local supermarket but it's pretty easy
to find a few Google sodium alginate so
this is a point eight percent solution
which is I put two grams of sodium
alginate into two points 250 grams of
Cal carrot juice so you need a pretty
accurate scale to do that so I'm going
to took a little bit of this up into my
syringe which i also got at the same
vendor as I got the alginate and drop it
into this setting back which is water
with a couple of grams of calcium
chloride dissolved in and that's that's
a pretty common salt so here we go
so I'm making nice caviar size drips I'm
sort of imagining salmon roe size rather
than ikura you know flying fish roe size
so I put about a dozen of these in here
and what's happening now is the calcium
in the calcium chloride is causing the
sodium alginate to start to gel from the
outside so the ideal product is has a
thin skin of tasteless flavorless gel
around carrot juice and that takes about
30 seconds or so which I'm going to say
this is actually it feels like it's been
about 20 seconds and I'll test them and
they seem to be holding together pretty
well so I'll pull these guys out of here
and dump them into this rinsing bath
which is just plain water so what the
rinsing bath does stops the chemical
reaction and holds them at the texture I
want and here we go I've got a dozen or
so little carrot caviar beads if I can
chase these guys out they kind of like
it in there but if I can chase bears one
out and it's got a nice consistency I
can move it around it it doesn't
dissolve into heat so I can throw it
into soup I can throw it onto ice cream
I can throw it into gym I made care of
martinis with this but when you when you
put into your mouth and hit it with your
tongue bang the the skin breaks the
sodium alginate disappears then you've
just got carrot juice so it's nothing
chemically nothing weird very very nice
tasting and this is a kind of way you
can deliver you know as a flavor like a
delicate flavor right to somebody's
palate I've seen olive oil caviar S&T
Caviar's and meets Caviar's
and it's a really fun fun kind of
garnish